i'm looking to my right and seeing one
of my favorite people to be here as an
in-studio guest and he's here as an
in-studio guest this is amazing to see
you
graeme ray hall in advance of the acura
grand prix of long beach that goes down
this sunday in the indy car season
finale how are you brother i'm good man
thank you good to see you how's your
family how's everything everything's
great uh baby girl's 10 months old now
almost 11 months dude just growing like
crazy that is so cool understanding what
life is now really all about right which
is awesome right um no it's been great
what's her name harlan harland harlan
anne yep harlan and ray so uh
it's been cool the uh she's you know
she's been able to travel to most the
races um you know which has been which
has been good because i mean travel is
kind of funny as it is i mean luckily
with indycar most of the most of the
early part of the season was kind of in
the south and then the midwest and
obviously as things kind of opened up
even further right here we are finishing
our season portland and two races in
california so it's been fairly easy to
get hurt all those races and it's been
cool i mean the long beach
uh the grand prix of long beach is just
such a historic big time race yeah do
you feel that history when you're out
there well of course i mean what do you
for sure i mean it's what 45 years or so
something around there
um
you know and i think too that people in
this area you know in southern
california i mean whether you're a
racing fan or not you know if you say
the long beach grand prix people know
you know people know and typically know
it's april um
clearly we're still adjusting and it's
it's our finale this year next year it
will go back to april which would be
good right but it's cool because people
appreciate you know what what the event
is and i it helped you know change that
city too i mean when the first grand
prix was there long beach was not the
best place to uh to be
um and uh you know it's uh it's
certainly improved a ton it's a
beautiful venue uh the racetrack hasn't
changed much over the years yeah so the
ride you went on is the same as the ride
i'll get all weekend and uh you know
it's uh it's been cool yeah i know we
just showed a video of of uh me riding
uh with mario andretti took me around
and and i get out
of you know the spin around with him
and i'm saying on on the video like you
do this for a living what what what is
the matter with you i think i said that
to you because you had just walked yes i
think of course at that time and that's
so i guess i'll
i mean it is
unbelievable what is it like to be
behind the wheel of a car on a course
like this one well it's tight you know
there's no margin for air uh zero but i
think that's also from a mental
standpoint that's what makes i think
racing so intense and makes the driving
aspect of it so hard is you know you
have to memorize every single bump
around there and you have to memorize
every single wall and apex and where i
need to be and if i hit this bump while
i'm turning it's going to move me this
amount of feet or inches and therefore i
have to give myself this kind of margin
but you know again though this place
doesn't change that much and luckily the
weather in southern california is always
good so the track itself doesn't change
correct there's places that we go to
this place that we race particularly in
the midwest you get a hot summer cold
winter you know pavement changes a
little bit you go there the next year
and suddenly there's bumps and there's
no water there the year before so it's
basically like coarse knowledge like a
caddy has a course
like is there something like that for
you well we don't have a book other than
just notes that you may take on your
phone or uh at the end of every race
weekend we do detailed notes uh to the
engineers so that we know when we go
back there next year we're gonna study
this and you know these are things that
we may experience and if we do this is
how we reacted it worked or it didn't
right um but yeah everything uh it is
you could almost use a caddy book if you
had one um because every single corner
all the straightaways even where you
just drive down the straightaways i mean
sometimes you know in our cars because
how low they sit to the ground i mean
you hit a big bump on the straightaway
it can really shave off a lot of
straight line speed so you know where do
you drive down the streets you got to
remember all of those things like
they've been racing on long beach for a
while yes so fairly used to it now and
uh we're looking forward to a good
weekend and hopefully finishing the
season off strong brockman this is the
point where you tell graham that when
you made a left
uh a right turn
from the left lane into the aquarium
that you might have taken a chunk out of
the road like this is where i think you
need to come clean chris yeah because
that isn't that when you said you were
prior to the olympics here on nbc sports
on peacock we we we mentioned what we're
all we would win a gold medal if this
was a sport fill in the blank what was
your sport this time
my olympic sport would be graham uh
quarter mile or less to go
i'm in the far left lane and i will
cross over three four five
lanes of traffic and make the exit there
you go one time so that says that's what
he would win the gold in that i will
make it every time out here in l.a you
get a lot of practice with that oh gosh
you ought to be extremely absolutely not
just northeast just north
you didn't do it at long beach though i
mean this man i know i haven't done it
at long beach okay 405 95 yeah anything
with a five experience yeah
my mine was two bounce tennis like if
you give me a second bounce at tennis i
would win the gold medal i actually
agree with that i like i like two bounce
tennis yeah that makes it a lot easier
for sure and a lot more fun i mean one
bounce is i feel like one bounce for me
it's over so fast could you imagine you
get a second bounce yeah it'd be great
please fetter my ass yeah right
you know pretty much i got graham ray
hall here on the rich eisen show and
you're very nice you brought this
this uh this version die cast yes this
die cast that's the indy 500 car so
that's a special edition we don't even
sell those this is very impressive
very special i love it and it's got uh
on it an inscription
uh rich happy birthday because i was
told it's your birthday it's all good no
you're a few months late but it's okay
yeah it's all good well it's the first
time i've seen you so it's still valid
and then what it says here i think i
think i think i read what it says
uh with your autograph very much
appreciated go bucks
that's what it says right here right so
i could ever give you anything and not
say it says go bucks on it and you don't
i when did you become a milwaukee fan
winning the championship you know you
know where i'm going with that when did
you
when did you start i'm not a milwaukee
fan
okay i feel like saying go buckeyes is
very uncomfortable understood that's way
too much so i've got a trivia question
uh-oh when was the last time michigan
beetle has no uh no it's a little more
current than that yeah it's more current
yeah it's more current yeah so you've
heard you heard how oklahoma and texas
joined the sec right yeah so upset a
whole apple cart and started a a a
domino effect yes where you know and
cincinnati is now going to the big 12.
right so a lot of dominoes moving and so
the big ten reached out to the pac-12
yeah and the acc to form what they
called an historic alliance yeah okay
there it is right there there's the the
graphic right there acc big ten and the
pac-12 so in the history of the historic
alliance which is not vast it's only a
couple weeks uh which team
won the first game in the history of the
historic alliance amongst conferences
from said historic lines which one for
the big ten came up with that one i'm
gonna guess it's your team that's
correct it would be michigan
it would be michigan correct i'm writing
it down to make sure that we remember it
over washington well washington is
terrible
well terrible i don't know if i would
call kids who try and compete terrible
okay
and i will say look i knew that this was
going to get heated today because
you guys look a lot better i mean i
don't know what else to say no we do i
mean
once they play michigan state still
early it's still early but when you're
trying to strike a blow on behalf of a
conference
um and you get an opponent in your house
from another conference in the historic
alliance we fly you wanna you wanna
stand your goal oh no
part of the trivia question correct
let's see if you can complete it
which team failed oh i know that in the
first attempt at trying to win one for
the historic alliance the big ten which
is the first team the first time we've
ever lost team
it's just
the hint is they're inscribed on this
beautiful cast iron
yeah i'm well aware rich
i didn't have uh i didn't bring a lot of
ammo for you today because i do that's
all i got that's uh i'm out i'm out of
um
i'm out of uh
season yes by a whole season and it's
not even mine uh but my as a fan yes
is now just can we beat michigan you
know what it's rejection it's really all
i that's so stupid it's so stupid you
got a whole schedule in between like the
other games don't matter i mean not
really at this stage i mean that's the
one
that's it that's the one because you
know again we don't live for it we don't
live for you you know what i mean we
live for for
for going to rome and you know doing all
these fancy things yes we are trying to
live our lives but um look the number of
times i'm already hearing it i'm hearing
it from you i'm hearing it from others
and i'm i'm about to hear from you i
know the defense would be mike you might
be able to get us this year i'm hearing
that already and i don't want to hear it
with ohio state tv yes yeah but they
were bad last year too and the year
before that
so you're concerned i think it just
comes down to who can score the most and
i don't know you know i mean you may not
have even seen this but they just
announced it cj stroud starting
quarterbacks out for this weekend right
um so you're going to see two other
that's the thing with ohio state i will
say and you can even admit this they are
so young that i don't understand like
you have four freshman quarterbacks two
red shirts two true right i mean at some
point
you know
all i know is there's no experience
there all i know is that there was a
quarterback once upon a time your school
not so long ago who i was told in fact
by ryan day himself when he called into
this program that he's really green he's
really green and i don't know what he's
going to be able to do we're going to
try and coach him and all that sort of
stuff and he threw 50 touchdown passes
and this was after the green kid
went into a game in the big house when
jt barrett got hurt yeah i thought okay
that's good for us and dwayne haskins no
joining us
so i i think he's gonna i hope that for
dwayne like
dwayne haskins is awesome i hope that
the steelers are
like some sort of a good opportunity for
him to get outside of what happened in
washington because he that kid had tons
of talent now he didn't play much in
college right he only played one season
and then you know and then moved on and
right you know and obviously you got
fields who's
going on hopefully this weekend have a
good weekend
i think he i i think he's going to be
just fine i think he's going to be
really good actually smart i mean smart
player so
look i mean we'll see we just graham ray
hall here on the rich eisen show we just
established that urban meyer was quoted
by the head coach of the denver broncos
vic fangio as saying
it's like playing alabama every week in
the nfl like look man i mean justin
fields threw the entire route tree on
top of clemson oh yeah i mean he was
phenomenal big time in that game and
clemson's defense you know half of it's
been drafted by the raiders in mayhawk
pretty much over the last two years
i just think the moment's not gonna be
too big for him he's back in ohio which
i don't know if that will matter to him
or not it's in cleveland but i mean it's
just there'll be buckeye fans in the
stands i don't know if they'll be
rooting for the bears or not but
i
i just i kind of believe i mean if you
look like jersey sales what'd they say
he's third highest jersey sales since
the draft and you know he's uh he's a
heck of a player
and
i mean i just i don't know man i feel
like you know andy dalton's had how many
chances now and it's just not working
out and i understand he got hurt but
like right you know fields is a guy like
i think fields is certainly capable you
look at like what um
you know what shanahan's doing with with
uh with trey lance like get just getting
them in letting them do some plays i
mean he's been able to score he's been a
part of it um working him in like i mean
it doesn't feel like fields has really
had that opportunity sure he's played
one or two plays but not not much and
it'll be interesting to see what happens
when he can get in and just kind of play
play a whole game um
the kid is so talented he is i mean he
is so talented yeah yeah there's no
there's no reason to believe that he
you know they if they want to say that
he's not ready
then how are any of the other guys
they're not like that's the thing like
when are you ready i mean i guess you
gotta you gotta go and you gotta play
and
um and you're gonna learn you're gonna
throw some pics you're gonna have some
ups and downs but i just feel like uh i
feel it's a good opportunity for him
yeah and uh i'm excited to see you know
excited to see what he can what he can
do no question i totally agree i'm not
even a bears fan my whole family's from
chicago i find the bears
mostly annoying probably like people
find ohio state fans mostly annoying yes
but i am excited to see
you know not to correct you uh i find
ohio state fans completely annoying not
mostly i'm sure you know and that
includes you who i genuinely like
personally um and which is why i'm just
going to tell you you know i think
justin fields is going to be very
successful and plus all he's got to do
is just be marginally better than mike
tomzack or kent graham and he's the
greatest ohio state quarterback in
history
so you know you know so
you know like there's a bar and it's set
like you know it's down here down here
right especially when the bar being set
by the greatest michigan quarterback to
ever play in the nfl like there's a roof
here and we got to go very tight
like we got to go above you've got to i
don't even know
that's just the greatest quarterback and
i've told you this yes i was not a tom
brady fan at all why because he played
in michigan okay and now i find like i'm
a big tom brady fan because i'm getting
older in my sport and in racing you know
you age and man the aches and the pains
and how do i stay ahead of it now i'm
competing with kids that are my when i
started i was 18. you know and now
you've got kids that are 21 22 you know
young that are doing this and i'm like
you know i i how do i stay ahead of this
right and yet you see brady and you
start to as a guy like me who competes
in a whole different sport right indycar
racing very different than nfl no but
it's just but you can appreciate
how has this guy been able to do it how
does he bounce you know back and forth
and i had we had a couple uh players
come to the saint pete uh scottie miller
was one of them yes and asking him about
brady in the mental aspect he said this
all week i mean he pounded into
everybody's head super bowl week we're
gonna win this is how we're gonna win
this is what we're gonna do and then you
know you take that in my sport and how
how can i keep my mechanics fired up how
do i get my engineers you know engaged
every single weekend um there's a lot
you can pull let alone the keeping your
body healthy and all that stuff but i
found myself to be a big fan i mean he's
not just the greatest michigan
quarterback he's the greatest
to ever
play this and if you you look at the
record it's staggering like we have a
guy in our sport scott dixon yes who's
the same and if you look at scott
dixon's record you look at how many wins
scott dixon has versus how many races
he's competed in the percentage
is ridiculous now you look at the amount
of top fives he's had or top tens
that those records will never be broken
like you can you know it's like 70
percent of the time he finishes in the
top 10 in a race when you think in
racing how many dnfs you have because
something fails or somebody punch you
and takes you out or you know just all
of these random mistakes that you may
you may make
you look at his record and it's like
brady it's just how how do you beat that
you know how do you uh
it's uh it's staggering and so you find
yourself being a fan and trying to
figure out what you can learn from
somebody in that in that position and
the crazy thing is you know he was gonna
go to michigan too i don't know if
you're aware of that
i'm sorry
no i'm sorry that was jeter my bad
madonna i'm sorry um my bad
you know just all-time greats just donna
did go to bishop
all right so i'm going to ask you if if
harbaugh loses to ohio state or michigan
state this year he's not going anywhere
you think he stays of course he does yes
of course he does you really think he's
the answer i don't want you know what
here's the deal
i just noticed this you have come in
here
which i'm thrilled about and i come here
you haven't said in a split you haven't
even said what are we going to do this
november you because you're you're i've
been waiting for you to ask i'm not
going to i'm not gonna i'm not gonna i'm
not going there and because there's
nothing there's no more gear that you
can put me in like yeah that's the
problem
exactly like we're we're done we're done
like i can't i don't know what to do
yeah so i don't think but i'm not gonna
go there yet i mean i i just like what
i've seen so far they're running the
heck out of the ball
i i and i know i i might be accused of
talking up an opponent but rutgers is
three and oh
and you know they yeah
i know they they are three and oh
there's not as many weak links anymore
nope you know shiano's gonna do well
maryland can can play here or there you
know they're going to put up some points
like they've got a lot of times
exactly that can they can surprise you
and at the same time it's like
whether you're ohio state or michigan
whoever you are you're always going to
get everybody's best shot period they're
gonna throw it all at you and that's
where like shiano even with rutgers last
year against ohio state like he's
throwing every trick
trick play in the book no doubt you
never know what can happen but uh
anyway before i let you go how's
letterman how's he doing letterman's
doing well um in fact i'll see him i
haven't seen him much this year but
we're doing a big uh charity event for
my wife my foundation called vino for
vets yep in napa in about a month and
dave's going to come out he's going to
kind of do a 20 30 minute mc uh how cool
is this event with uh with with a
well-known vet to uh to speak about ptsd
and all of the things we're trying to
raise money for and so we're excited
about that he's never you know it's the
first time i've ever asked him you know
to do something like that but he jumped
right in and you know he just calls me
and says he's back to work but i hear
from dave all the time every race
weekend tomorrow i'll hear from saturday
i'll hear from sunday you know long
beach is a big race ends the season for
us and he's he's super engaged i mean
he's watching
paying a lot of attention
maybe we'll get you ought to get him on
the show uh i would that would be i
don't even know i don't have words for
it to be honest he would do it i'll bet
you he'd do it i i you know
i would love to have him um and talk
about ball state i do this for a living
because of him i'm serious like
i mean he is he is an idol
that's awesome there is no doubt and
when i did the show as a guest
it was an out of body experience for me
yeah and as if you saw the cue cards
from that appearance is what's hanging
in my mind i did see that it's from that
one time with letterman he's he's an
all-time i mean that needs to be said
and if you could just say anything to
him my condolences to him on on norm
mcdonald passing away i know he was a
big fan of his and that was the last
comic to appear on his show yeah on his
run so yeah it's uh if you say that
obviously but um i'll send him a message
you're lucky man you're surrounded by
ghosts you're surrounded by goats and
thank you for this uh this birthday gift
yeah happy birthday i appreciate
everybody happy birthday it's okay my
birthday was right when the milwaukee
bucks won so it's very nice that you
included go bucks right here on it thank
you i really appreciate that erin
everyone check out uh again the grand
prix of long beach the acura grand prix
of long beach is this sunday and go to
grahamrahal.com
vino for vets
to make sure that we all uh jump in and
give as much money to your charitable
contributions for a terrific cause i
appreciate you coming here graeme you're
on yes thank you good to see you good to
see you guys hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here